[Musik]
guten abend liebe zuschauer ein bisschen
später als sie uns gewohnt sind und das
aber mit ganzer kraft gutes sie mit
dabei sind sein wort von der zeitenwende
ist hängen geblieben und das die er
keine wende zum guten ist das wird jeden
tag klarer ankaufen tanken alles wird
teurer und nachzahlungen für das heizen
drohen es kann ein sehr kalter winter
werden auch für ganze industriezweige
zum krieg in der ukraine der klimakrise
und corona jetzt also auch noch angst um
die jobs die müssen reden mit diesen
gästen
rifka lamprecht ist 21 sie studiert
politik hier geht es um klimaschutz und
eine gerechtere wirtschaft wir befinden
uns in einem klima notstand sagt sie
dagegen werde viel zu wenig getan
steffen stiebler und seine frau cornelia
führen eine bäckerei in thüringen 200
brote und 2500 brötchen täglich die
kosten für energie und weizen
explodieren bringen die bäckerei jetzt
an den rand des ruins
katharina micenko flüchtete im märz mit
ihrem sohn aus der ukraine nach berlin
die verlegerin sagt der krieg müsse mit
allen mitteln gestoppt werden sie ist
ungeduldig mit den deutschen und fragt
was ist wenn die stimmung kippt
ralf berning ist krankenpfleger auf
einer intensivstation
nach 15 jahren bundeswehr mit
afghanistan einsatz kämpft er jetzt um
das leben von patienten der
pflegenotstand bringt ihn oft ans limit
berning fordert mehr personal und einen
flächendeckenden mindestlohn
und bundeskanzler olaf scholz
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
die alle gäste natürlich sehr herzlich
begrüßt in dramatischen zeiten und zack
schon geht es los ralph benning ist bei
uns herr berning sie waren soldat in
afghanistan krieg sie sind jetzt pflege
auf einer intensivstation
und sie sind bald familienvater was
macht ihnen am meisten sorgen wenn sie
auf das kleine budget ihrer auf der s
budget ihrer kleinen familie kommen das
macht mir große sorgen weil unterm
strich schaut man natürlich wie viel
geld hat man jetzt zur verfügung und wie
viel geld hat man zur verfügung wenn man
dann die familie hat beziehungsweise die
frau dann natürlich auch erstmal in die
elternzeit geht dann fängt man an zu
rechnen und auch ich setze mich dann hin
zusammen mit meiner frau und wir fangen
an zu rechnen und wenn man dann auch
schon wie teuer dann ein kind ist
heutzutage war es ein kita-platz kostet
in nordrhein-westfalen und was auch die
erstausstattung betrifft was man alles
noch beschaffen muss oder ein
kinderzimmer was man renovieren muss
dann macht man sich da schon große
sorgen und wenn man dann jetzt in den
heutigen zeiten dann auch noch schaut
wie teuer zum beispiel strom oder gas
wird was auf uns zukommt sich dann
teilweise urlaubsgeld oder
weihnachtsgeld dann schon zur seite
legen weil ich nicht weiß wie viel
nachzahlung kommt auf mich zu dann macht
mir das sehr gross zusammen besonders
wenn man der familie gerade gründet
robert habeck hat gestern gesagt dass
allein bei den energiekosten da ein
monatseinkommen zusammenkommen kann
haben sie schon mal überlegt welcher
monat
ja unterm strich ist es natürlich
schwierig weil wenn man jetzt vor vier
jahren ein haus gekauft hat man hat das
saniert man steckt natürlich geld rein
ins haus man geht viel fürs haus
arbeiten und am ende des monats wenn man
dann guckt wo kann ich jetzt etwas zur
seite legen oder wenn ein gerät kaputt
geht dann schaut man schon wo holt man
das geld her und im endeffekt ist es bei
mir so dass wir gesagt haben okay das
ist ein teil von weihnachtsgeld und lass
uns da ein teil vom urlaubsgeld zur
seite legen weil wir nicht wissen was
auf uns zukommt dann nachzahlung heusel
zahlen sie parallel noch ab und hier ist
ihre frage an den bundeskanzler herr
bundeskanzler ich möchte gerne wissen
auf was muss ich mich vorbereiten was
kommt auf mich zu und lohnt es sich für
mich in der zukunft überhaupt noch voll
arbeiten zu gehen
die letzte frage wichtig beantworten
unbedingt sonst würde auch alles
zusammenbrechen nicht nur die pflege wo
sie sich engagieren sondern auch unser
land das beruht darauf dass so viele
männer und frauen berufstätig sind und
dazu beitragen dass wir unseren
wohlstand gemeinsam erwirtschaften aber
es muss natürlich auch so sein dass man
sich das leben leisten kann und gerade
jetzt durch die vielen steigenden preise
bei lebensmitteln bei energie ist es
schon so dass viele das beschreiben sie
ja auch nicht sicher sind ob die
rücklagen reichen wenn dann jetzt
ordentliche steigerung kommen wir haben
uns vorgenommen dass wir helfen soweit
wir das können mit unseren möglichkeiten
und haben deshalb erst mal ganz schnell
an zwei sofort pakete auf den weg
gebracht alles zusammen 30 milliarden
euro die helfen sollen dass man erst mal
in diesem jahr über die zeit kommt also
da sind viele maßnahmen weil die welt
nicht alle aufzählen aber dazu zählt zum
beispiel dass wir jetzt für kinder wo
das geld in der familie nicht so groß
ist jeden monat ab diesem monat 20 euro
mehr zahlen dass wir für alle kinder 100
euro zahlen dass es ein energie gilt
geld gibt dass wir auch ein bisschen
geholfen haben jetzt mit dem neuen euro
ticket und dem den verbilligten preisen
und den tankstellen weil wir steuern
verzichtet haben aber das alles zusammen
wird natürlich nicht auf dauer helfen
und das haben wir gesagt neben all dem
was wir auf den weg gebracht haben
wollen wir unbedingt auch sicherstellen
dass wir für die zukunft uns unterhaken
deshalb habe ich eingeladen zu einer
konzertierten aktion das gab's schon mal
in den 70er jahren zum beispiel als auch
solche probleme da waren damit
gewerkschaften arbeitgeberverbände sind
und eher verständigen und staat sich
darauf verständigen was wir machen da
werden dann auch neue schritte neue
maßnahmen daraus abgemacht dass zwischen
arbeitgebern und arbeitnehmern aber die
frage ist ja welche unterstützung gibt
der staat und da auch sie müssen erstmal
reinkommen herr bundeskanzler auch da
muss man ja aber sagen was bringt es
eigentlich den einzelnen gruppen in
dieser gesellschaft die bundesregierung
verspricht entlastung eine energie
kostenpauschale 300 euro einen
familienbonus von 100 euro pro kind den
befristeten tank rabatt und das neun
euro ticket für drei monate
eine familie mit zwei kindern
nettoeinkommen 2000 bis 2600 euro wird
dadurch um 1.000 sechs jahren
eine rentnerin mit einer rente von unter
900 euro nur um 46 euro
also das sind jahres beträge da kommen
tatsächlich eben an entlastungen dieses
monats einkommen bei familie
rangendingen nicht zustande die frage
ist empfehlen sie ihnen zu sparen
empfehlen sie ihnen sich bestimmte dinge
jetzt nicht mehr zu leisten oder wird es
darüber hinaus noch entlastungen geben
ich habe ihm gesagt wenn wir jetzt uns
zusammensetzen in der konzertierten
aktion dann ist es auch deshalb weil wir
finden dass jetzt alle ein beitrag dazu
leisten müssen dass die bürgern und
bürger gerade die mit geringen einkommen
zurechtkommen können und deshalb erwarte
ich auch dass aus diesem gespräch in der
konzertierten aktion noch weitere
maßnahmen kommen trotzdem kann ich ja
niemanden seriös versprechen dass das
was in der ganzen welt passiert was zu
diesen steigenden preisen führt auch der
krieg den russland gegen die ukraine vom
zaun gebrochen hat jetzt plötzlich
aufhört und alle probleme von einem tag
auf den anderen verschwinden wir
versuchen nur das beste zu unternehmen
auch damit zum beispiel die preise nicht
durch die decke gehen vorzusorgen uns
vorzubereiten auf diese lage aber
gleichzeitig ist es so dass wir eben
auch weitere hilfen durchaus überlegen
und das wollen wir aber nicht einfach
irgendwo in seiner stube
kanzleramt machen sondern das wollen wir
mit allen besprechen und daraus
entwickeln kommen wir auf jeden fall
noch mal wie groß dann die
lohnsteigerung sein müsste damit sie das
alles kompensieren können besprechen wir
nachdem wir vorgestellt haben dass an
dieser sendung auch steffen und cornelia
stiebeling teilnehmen sie sind uns aus
thüringen zugeschaltet einen guten abend
zu ihnen ihre familien bäckerei familie
stiebeling will eigentlich am 18
jubiläum feiern nämlich 100 jähriges
jubiläum feiern in der dritten
generation
traditionsbäckerei aber sie stehen vor
echt großen problemen wo drückt der
schuh am meisten wenn sie sagen müssen
der schuh drückt hauptsächlich an den
energie pro bleme das ist das
allergrößte problem dann sind es die
rohstoffkosten die explodiert sind
teilweise haben sie sich verdreifacht
die verpackungskosten und wir können die
preise nicht
überhaupt nicht weitergeben an unsere
kunden weil bei uns kostet ein brötchen
mittlerweile 70 cent
beim discounter kostet 20 cent und wenn
das geld knapp ist bei den leuten dann
hilft auch nicht mehr dass es bei uns
frisch gebacken ist und bäckerei und
tradition dann zählt nur noch das reine
geld und dann kommen die nicht mehr zu
uns dann geht unser betrieb dann auch
gleich mit 30 angestellten und wir sind
nicht die einzigen es gibt viele
betriebe die die gleichen probleme haben
gerade das kleine und mittlere handwerk
und die die regionalen betriebe die die
regionale wirtschaft am laufen halten
sie haben das muss man vielleicht noch
einmal erklären sie haben nicht so einen
länger laufenden energie vertrag zum
einen sondern sie kaufen ihr regelmäßig
jetzt eben monatsweise ihren strom und
ihr gas oder wie machen sie das
das wirst du meine frau antworten ja wir
waren bis jetzt die letzten jahre am
spot-markt dotiert es war für uns
eigentlich eine günstige lösung wir
hatten praktisch tages einkäufer und
unsere abschlagszahlung die waren so gut
positioniert dass wir sogar zum anfang
des neuen jahres immer noch einen
kleinen betrag zurückbekommen haben es
war ein bisschen wie eine sparbüchse
aber dann mit den letzten jahres haben
die preise derart angezogen dass wir
eben zum jahresanfang dieses jahr sonoro
rentennachzahlungen hatten für 221 und
darauf basierend gleichen vorauszahlung
für 2022 dass wir eigentlich im januar
schon vom ruin gestanden haben
mittlerweile ist es so wir konnten uns
da erst nochmal einigen und wir haben
auch jetzt den anbieter gewechselt im
bereich gas aber wie lange das gut geht
und wie lange peter beliefert werden
können und ob der preis den man uns im
märz april gegeben hat noch zu halten
ist das kann uns eben auch wie man
versprechen niemand voraussagen und die
preise die sie für mehl und butter und
bezahlen müssen die sind in nicht
genauso geschrieben aber auch gestiegen
die sind extrem gestiegen also wenn ich
jetzt öl nehmen das ist von
ein euro 9 im letzten jahr 275 dieses
jahr gestiegen er hat sich um 50 prozent
erhöht für unsere fertigkuchen die
verpackung hat sich um 50 prozent über
50 prozent erhöht das sind alles das
sind keine pennies beträge mehr das sind
extrem hohe beträge die ich aber nicht
weitergeben können weil ich die produkte
dann nicht mehr verkaufen können das
kann keiner mehr und hier ist ihre frage
an den bundeskanzler
herr scholz was wollen sie tun oder was
gedenken sie zu tun um die kleine und
mittlere heimische wirtschaft überhaupt
am leben zu erhalten da werden
kurzfristige hilfen nicht helfen da muss
was
grundsätzliches passieren wünscht sich
familie liebling herr scholz was können
sie tun um familien betrieben mit 20
angestellten die
lebensnotwendig sind bei der versorgung
der bevölkerung über diese harte strecke
zu helfen ja
ich erstmal muss ich sagen das ist ja
wirklich eine große herausforderung vor
dem dieses unternehmen und
stehen und die bäckerei und davor stehen
vor diesem haus vorn stehen ganz viele
unternehmen in deutschland das ist auch
etwas was an der realität ausmacht wir
versuchen langfristig uns aus diesen
abhängigkeiten zu befreien aber das wird
uns nicht morgen und nicht im nächsten
jahr helfen wir haben gerade heute viele
beschlüsse gefasst dass wir strom aus
erneuerbaren energien produzieren wollen
damit der auch dauerhaft auf dauer
billiger sein wird aber das ist nicht
jetzt das wird sich hinziehen bis das
dann sich bei den preisen auch
niederschlägt und deshalb versuchen wir
jetzt alles was in unserer macht steht
dazu beizutragen dass wir jedenfalls
nicht
allzu schwer explodierender
energiepreise haben wir haben deshalb
sehr schnell begonnen dafür zu sorgen
dass unsere import strukturen für gas
verbessert werden indem wir neue
terminals bauen damit wir empfangen
haben von der familie ist ja auch für
die großen unternehmen führende
lufthansa damals und jetzt für juniper
ist geld da sind starts stützungen da
tun sie und was tun sie konkret für den
mittelstand das sind ja 80 prozent der
deutschen mutter wir werden nicht alle
preise
unter subventionieren können ich glaube
so viel wahrheit gehört dazu das kann
kein staat der welt das können auch wir
nicht obwohl wir erheblich mehr
finanzielle möglichkeiten verfügen als
viele andere aber wir sind gewillt sehr
genau zu gucken was man unternehmen kann
auch um unternehmen zu stützen deshalb
haben wir erst mal alle möglichen
programme die mit fördermöglichkeiten
der kaffee und andere verbunden sind
wieder aktiviert und sind auch dabei
noch weitere auf den weg zu bringen und
man kann sich darauf verlassen dass die
gespräche die wir führen in der von mir
schon eben beschriebenen konzertierten
aktion ja nicht nur darum gehen wie
helfen wir jetzt arbeitnehmern was ist
das eine große thema wie wir den
bürgerinnen und bürgern helfen mit den
preisen zurechtzukommen das geht auch
darum was tun wir für die wirtschaft in
diesem bereich und wir sind fest
entschlossen niemanden alleine zu lassen
ob das gilt für alle bürgerinnen und
bürger des landes aber es gilt auch für
die bäckereien in deutschland wie lange
halten sie noch durch
familie liebling
wir wissen es nicht wir wissen s
wirklich nicht es ist ein wunder dass
wir das wir heute noch da sind als wir
die rechnung im januar bekommen haben
das war ein derartiger schock wir hatten
gerade die lohnzahlung zu der zeit
konnten die löhne nicht pünktlich
bezahlen da hatten wir schon da an ein
riesenproblem
wir haben aus der familie mein
schwiegervater hat noch geld mit
eingelegt
befreundete firmen lieferant hat geld
eingelegt wir haben das irgendwie über
die bühne gekriegt und wir haben bis
jetzt
ich weiß nicht wie es meine frau gemacht
hat aber wir haben es geschafft bis
hierher zu kommen und ich bin auch
irgendwie gut und dinge irgendein wunder
geschehen oder muss geschehen dass es
weitergeht aber es kann so kein zustand
seien es erst gar nicht funktionieren
dass das wir
ja irgendwie versuchen zu überleben das
ja keine zukunft vielleicht da windows
sagen das problem dass wir
hier hören ist ja ein problem das uns
zeigt wie groß die herausforderung noch
werden wird denn viele unternehmen und
auch viele privatkunden haben wir noch
verträge die länger laufen dh die haben
meinen vertrag dasteht bis zu dem datum
sind die preise festgesetzt ist genauso
wie sie sagen das wird für sehr viel
mehr menschen und sehen müssen uns ist
klar machen dass das was bei einigen
sofort durch schlecht weil sie praktisch
an den spotmärkten sich ihre
energie gekauft haben so wie das hier
geschildert worden ist dass das bei uns
allen später durchschlagen wird und
deshalb ist es so wichtig dass wir jetzt
alles unternehmen um möglichst gut damit
zurecht zu kommen wir werden nur nicht
versprechen können dass wir verhindern
dass die gaspreise auf dem weltmarkt
steigen wir werden nicht versprechen
können dass die ölpreise auf dem
weltmarkt dass wir verhindern dass die
ölpreise auf dem weltmarkt steigern wir
können nur versuchen das beste aus der
schwierigen situation zu machen das aber
wollen wir und deshalb wie gesagt nicht
irgendwo der einzelentscheidung sondern
mit vielen zusammen beraten das wollen
sie mit vielen zusammen beraten wir
stellen erst mal die anderen gäste vor
und versuchen da nachher noch mehr ins
detail zu gehen weil man ja verstehen
möchte was kann man eigentlich tun
stützt man die versorger wird man
anteilig die kunden also die abnehmer
und konsumenten mehr zur kasse bitten
müssen darüber werden wir noch reden
rifka lamprecht ist bei uns studentin
aus berlin es gibt hilfen für familien
es gibt hilfen für große unternehmen es
gibt hilfe für den transport und das du
dich tauchen in all den dingen irgendwie
auch sie und ihre generation auf
hambrecht haben sie das gefühl
also außer dem neuen euro ticket ist bei
mir persönlich nichts angekommen aber
das ist nicht meine größte sorge sondern
ein größte sorge ist dass junge menschen
langfristig die verlierer dieser
krisenzeiten werden wollen wir so
weitermachen wir haben hier eine
klimakrise die immer weiter von kurras
brandenburg brands seit wochen nicht
weit von hier
wir haben ein gravierendes rentensystem
dem wir entgegenwirken und ist als
bisher auf ihre agenda hatte ich viel
passiert und wir haben unglaublich viele
schulden durch die milliarden hilfen an
unternehmen die klimaschädlich sind und
wie ihr wisst dass am ende alles
schultern und das macht mir große sorgen
wenn nicht sogar angst wir stehen herr
scholz ist die frage vor einem
staatsbankrott nein überhaupt nicht alle
vorhersagen sind etwa so dass wir in
ganz kurzer zeit das also wenn es jetzt
nicht an großen wirtschaftseinbruch gibt
und der krieg eskaliert und die folgen
für die ganze welt dazu führen dass es
ganz anders kommt aber wenn es normal
weiter läuft werden wir in relativ
kurzer zeit das schuldenniveau wieder
erreichen dass bevor der korona krise
hatten also auf 60 prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung zurückkommen weil
deutschland über eine große
wirtschaftskraft verfügt mit der wir
dann in der lage sind das wachstum
zustande zu bringen dass dazu notwendig
ist deshalb muss der staat ja ja ja ist
aber der staatsbankrott steht natürlich
nicht bevor und ich will auch erste
anlage dieser generation einen riesigen
schuldenberg kärnten wird aber die
grundlage für alles was man mit krediten
bezahlt ist dass man sie zurückzahlen
kann dass man die kredite bedienen kann
und dass man eine große wirtschaftskraft
hat und da spricht schon viel dafür dass
deutschland ein land ist bei dem das der
fall ist ich habe heute gerade den
grundstein für eine batteriefabrik
gelegt in salzgitter ich habe wir wissen
dass es mehrere andere gibt die in
deutschland gebaut worden sind es gibt
ganz erhebliche milliardenschwere
investitionen der ganzen industrie eine
elektrifizierte mobilität zum beispiel
aber das ist nur ein teil von allem nein
die deutsche volkswirtschaft hat alle
potenziale dafür zu sorgen dass wir
unsere wirtschaft stark sind dass wir
die kredite bedienen können und im
vergleich zu vielen anderen ländern
werden wir ganz gut rauskommen wir haben
ja schon am ende der korona krise
weniger schulden gehabt als die meisten
unserer
befreundete länder die zum beispiel bei
den g 7 staaten zusammenkommen also in
wirtschaftsstarken demokratie sehr der
krise hatten noch haben wir auch
überhaupt kein nachfrageproblem aber wir
haben offensichtlich ein material
problem ein energieproblem eine
arbeitskräfte problem wir sind in dieser
situation
und damit begrüße ich unseren vierten
gast hier am tisch katharina mir
schenken sie sind seit märz diesen
jahres in berlin aus der ukraine
geflohen mit ihrem sohn ihr mann ist
immer noch in der ukraine
und die frage ist natürlich wie sehr
fühlen sie sich von der regierung von
der politik hier unterstützt im
vergleich zu all den freiwilligen
helfern
die ihnen begegnet sind sie hierherkamen
das ist zunächst die erste frage und wie
empfinden sie deutschland gerade auch in
bezug auf die stimmung der menschen ihre
sorgen ja ich glaube es war eine
ziemlich logische dynamik erstmal gab es
sehr viel solidarität und auch sehr viel
unterstützung von
deutschen bürgern er und ich glaube das
wird oft in unseren medien wenig
diskutiert aber das hat schon eine ganz
wichtige rolle gespielt auch für die
soziale unterstützung der ukraine in
dieser zeit und das stellt sich wirklich
und die zahlen von
ukrainerinnen ukraine die nach
deutschland geflüchtet sind sind ja hoch
also neben unseren unmittelbaren
nachbarn polen ja hier ist deutschland
auch da ganz
aktiv tran und ich glaube es war auch
logisch dass von dieser dass diese
gesellschaftliche unterstützung eine
garantie war für die politik der politik
auch diesen weg der solidarität mit der
ukraine geht und ich glaube das sehen
wir heute auch an der diskussion
es gibt
auch probleme die mit diesem krieg
unmittelbar verbunden sind und es gibt
genug herausforderungen
deshalb kann man von der gesellschaft
auch nicht erwarten dass sie die ganze
zeit so mobilisiert ist für die hilfe
für ukrainerinnen aber da ist die
politik ganz wichtig damit diese
unterstützung konsequent bleibt unter
diese solidarität jetzt in die politik
integriert wird ja genau und für eine
längere zeit leider sieht so aus dass
das ein langer weg sein wird
fürchten sie und das ist ihre frage an
den bundeskanzler befürchten sie dass
die politik der wankelmütig werden ja
das interessiert mich wie das für sie
ist wie fest ist
jetzt die politik die auch die sich auch
entwickelt hat in diesen monaten und wie
wird es aussehen wenn die
gesellschaftliche unterstützung
nachlässt und wenn die schwerpunkte also
die akzente auch in medien andere werden
nicht mehr der krieg und die sendung
solidarität nachlässt ja herr scholz
zunächst mal ich sehe das so wie sie das
beschrieben haben es hat eine
unglaubliche solidarität vieler
bürgerinnen und bürger in deutschland
gegeben mit den
frauen männern und kindern die aus der
ukraine geflohen sind wir haben jetzt in
unserem ausländerzentralregister knapp
900.000 registriert dass es wirklich
eine sehr sehr große zahl und eigentlich
ist niemand sehr aufgeregt sondern es
sind unverändert sehr viele sehr
hilfreich der solidarische sind
verändert viele ukraine und kräne privat
untergekommen bei bürgern und bürgern
dieses landes die ihre hilfe angeboten
haben sonst würde das uns viel
schwieriger fallen und auch in den
schulen und den kindergärten sind viele
kinder aus der ukraine und nicht alle
auf seine chance bleiben sie bei bleibt
die politik bei ihrer solidarität haben
sie sorge dass wenn die preise weiter so
sehr steigen dass die menschen angst
davor haben und in ihrem leben nach
schnellen lösungen suchen wollen also 47
prozent der menschen in diesem land
sagen heute sie wünschen sich
zugeständnisse der ukraine gebiete
abzugeben im süden und im osten damit
diese sanktionen aufhören wie lange
werden sie stehen wie lange wird diese
regierung stehen
einsatz würde ich noch sagen wir haben
ja auch etwas gemacht was sehr hilfreich
ist für die unterstützung derjenigen die
hier als
hierhergekommen sind in dem wir gesagt
haben sie haben zugang zu unserem
arbeitsmarkt und können sich auch auf
das unterstützungssystem für
arbeitsuchende
zurückgreifen und das funktioniert jetzt
auch ganz gut das haben wir das erste
mal so gemacht und es zeigt sich dass es
das richtige ist wir werden solange
solidarisch sein dass ich als meinen
wunsch wie das notwendig ist damit die
ukraine sich verteidigen kann gegen den
fruchtbaren und brutalen russischen
angriff auf das eigene land wir können
nicht akzeptieren dass ein land seinen
nachbarn über feld und sagte ich tausche
ich glaube mir ein stück vom von der
fläche gehört jetzt mir das ist ja im
prinzip die idee die hinter putins
angriffskrieg steht und das kann man
nicht akzeptieren
darum werden wir die finanzielle die
humanitäre hilfe das werden wir auch das
was wir am waffenlieferung auf den weg
gebracht dann weiterführen und dazu
zählen aber auch die sanktionen über die
wir uns ja mit unglaublich vielen
anderen ländern verständigt haben man
muss sagen ein teil der probleme die wir
jetzt haben
würden aus dem russischen angriffskrieg
das gilt insbesondere für steigende
lebensmittelpreise weil der weizenexport
aus der ukraine behindert worden ist wir
hoffen sehr dass wir das jetzt ändern
können das gilt auch für viele andere
dinge die damit verbunden sind natürlich
gibt kommt ein teil der probleme aber
auch aus längerfristigen trends und
kommt trotzdem habe ich danach gefragt
wie lange halten sie das durch und wie
lange werden sie auch gegen eine
stimmung regieren und durchhalten herr
scholz dass diese sanktionen bestehen
bleiben die nicht nur die lebensmittel
und lebenshaltungskosten sondern die
energiepreise und alles teuer machen wir
hätten auch so eine inflation aber sie
werden nicht so hoch wie wir sie jetzt
wie lange machen sie politik gegen eine
stimmung ich glaube dass man immer nur
mit der unterstützung der bürgerinnen
bürger agieren kann habe ich glaube dass
das sehr lange möglich sein wird und
dass wir so lange wie es notwendig ist
die solidarität mit der ukraine aus
deutschland heraus aufrechterhalten
können ich habe ja von anfang an immer
sehr vorsichtig agiert und habe versucht
mich mit vielen abzustimmen weil ich das
genau für richtig halte aber vielleicht
ist das jetzt auch die grundlage dafür
dass wenn es schwieriger wird und wir
probleme sehen die aus diesem krieg
heraus auch für uns erkennbar werden und
daraus erwachsen dass dann auch die
solidarität immer noch hält und das ist
mein eindruck und ich glaube dass wir da
als bürgern und bürger dieses landes das
tun werden wozu wir auch unser selbst
wegen verpflichtet sind nämlich dafür zu
sorgen dass demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit um die an land ringt
nicht einfach mit gewalt untergraben
werden die familie stieblich steffen und
cornelia stickling haben gerade zum
thema abhängigkeit von russischen gas
auch noch eine frage und eine anmerkung
deutschland hat sich in den letzten 20
jahren praktisch komplett abhängig
gemacht von russischer energie von öl
von gas von kohle ich weiß nicht was
alles und ich bin der meinung
wenn russland unser einziger quasi
einziger energielieferant ist wie kann
ich dann gegen dieses land wenn es mit
einem drittstaat probleme hat
ich verstehe die solidarität mit der
ukraine ich habe selber gerade
abgenommen ist alles sehr verständlich
aber ich deutschland kann doch nicht
gegen einen staat von dem von teams
abhängig ist derartige ist sanktionen
verhängen und immer wieder das feuer
schüren das verstehe ich nicht also wie
lange soll das noch funktionieren und
kurzfristig kann man das gas nicht
ersetzen da ist die frage sanktionen
gegen russland verhängen gegen ein land
verhängen von dem man so abhängig ist
sie nicht da haben wir das ja nie
alleine getan sondern mit vielen anderen
in europa und in der welt zusammen und
wir haben aber immer darauf geachtet
dass für solche sanktion festsetzen den
oder schaden bei uns wo der schaden bei
uns nicht größer ist als bei anderen
deshalb haben wir gesagt wir werden im
herbst auf die import den import von
kohle aus russland verzichten können das
funktioniert auch technisch wir arbeiten
jeden tag daran dass auch die transporte
mit der bahn funktionieren kein
einfaches thema aber etwas das man lösen
kann wir haben gehen davon aus dass wir
auch ölimporte zum jahreswechsel
verzichten können auch da arbeiten wir
dran das ist bei kohle und öl in den
meisten fällen nicht so schwierig weil
das schon immer verschifft worden es ist
eben wirklich richtig dabei zwei
raffinerien dass er und sein da kann man
jetzt darum das ist ja auch funktioniert
und das ist beim gast nicht so deshalb
gibt es auch kein gas embargo der
europäischen union und von irgendwem
sonst erst jetzt die lieferungen
gedrosselt worden sind ist eine mit
technik begründete einseitige
entscheidung des russischen
gaslieferanten dafür gibt es keine
gründern aus dem st der technik die die
glaubten sie sowieso nicht versteht
die mögen also es wird mit der technik
begründet aber der westen liefert den
russen ja auch die dass das argument
über die technik man könnte ja diese
turbine
einfach durch lassen und dann ist dieses
dieses argument zumindest weg sagt auch
klaus müller
bundesagentur dass es eher eine
politische abschaltung geben können
wenigstens ist das zu befürchten ich
würde gerne noch mal nachfragen bei
ihnen gibt es denn einen notfallplan bei
ihnen oder
informiert sie jemand ob sie tatsächlich
in einer bestimmten alarmstufe dann mit
gas versorgt werden und das noch bekämen
wir haben versucht uns uns zu erkundigen
ob sowas gibt bislang gibt es das nicht
wenn das also ich hoffe dass wir da bin
lebensmittelbetrieb sind das wird das
letzte bisschen gas noch kriegen aber
wenn es kein gas mehr gibt dann gibt es
kein gas mehr dann können nicht mehr
packen dann ist feierabend dann wäre der
ofen aus trage auch der um
die versorgung möchte ich mal aus also
die um gegen wir sehen dann klein
versorger für regionale
bürgerinnen und bürger und wenn wir dann
nicht mehr packen können wir nicht mehr
ausliefern können das betrifft ja nicht
nur uns sondern viele viele
kleinbetriebe dann ist ein bisschen
hunger vorprogrammiert
meinung dass man dann nicht
ich bin der meinung dass man jetzt alles
auf den tisch legen sollte und über
alles reden sollte und man muss auch mit
mit den russen reden vielleicht das nord
stream zwei aufmachen oder dergleichen
dass das irgendwie weitergeht ich kann
doch nicht dieses land komplett vor die
wand fahren
weil ich gegen den krieg bin ja das ist
ja alles richtig aber
der schaden ist unermesslich der da
entsteht herr schatz einmal wir haben
spitze nur noch mal wiederholen keine
sanktionen in bezug auf gas verhängt
aber sie haben sanktionen verhängt und
dann ist doch logisch das ist wie gesagt
das hat putin gelegenheit zu sagen habe
ich mich seitdem ich kanzler bin mit der
frage beschäftigt was passiert
eigentlich wenn die energielieferung
gefährdet sind weil ich das immer für
eine mögliche eskalation das ja schon
damals vorhandenen konflikts gehalten
habe und wir haben dann sehr sorgfältig
aufgearbeitet was wir tun müssen und als
der krieg losging habe ich dann auch
viele dinge sagen können zum beispiel
dass wir in größtem tempo dafür sorgen
dass wir andere import strukturen haben
wir bauen also richtig pipelines mit
riesiger geschwindigkeit hersteller
dieses haben sie an vielen stellen
entschuldigung wenn ich unterbreche ich
muss schon erzählt aber wie ist das
jetzt ja es war söder fordert jetzt
einen stresstest von ihnen ja aber ich
möchte die frage doch einmal so sagen
wir haben dafür sorge getragen dass all
das gemacht wird was man tun kann dazu
zählt erstens dass wir andere import
strukturen technisch überhaupt möglich
machen erde arbeit mit tempo drin
zweitens haben wir ein gesetz gemacht
das vorschreibt dass in den speichern
gas eingespeichert werden muss wir haben
jetzt schon mehr eingespeichert als im
letzten jahr meine vorsorge getroffen
haben drittens haben wir jetzt ein
gesetz gemacht das dazu führt dass wir
im sommer
kohlekraftwerke zum betrieb in den
zuschauer nehmen damit wir gas sparen
viertens ist nicht ausgemacht dass es zu
der mangel lage tatsächlich kommt es
wäre nur völlig unverantwortlich sie
nicht als möglichkeit in sachlicher zu
leben und sich darauf vorzubereiten
und deshalb haben wir auch gesetze auf
den weg gebracht mit denen wir als staat
die macht haben zu handeln das ist jetzt
gerade auch in dieser woche der
insgesamten dabei stehen und da zählt
zum beispiel dass wir uns
eine dass wir ein system erarbeiten wie
wir zusammen mit der wirtschaft genau
verstehen können wer bei wem gas
abschaltung welche folgen hat wir wollen
auch ein instrument arbeiten mit dem wir
unternehmen die sagen ich könnte ein
paar monate darauf verzichten geld geben
wenn sie das tun dann mit gas für andere
da ist und genau die probleme lösen die
die bäckerei hat und viele andere
unternehmen auch damit wir das möglichst
vernünftig hinkriegen wir bereiten uns
also wirklich jeden tag mit großem
großer intensität darauf vor dass eine
solche lage entstehen kann er nur noch
ist sie nicht passiert noch ist sie
nicht passiert aber es besteht ja
offensichtlich auch eine große sorge bei
lambrecht nicht nur sie haben das
verfolgt dass man plötzlich auch darüber
diskutiert wer den vorrang kommt es gibt
eigentlich eine gesetzliche grundlage
bei der energieversorgung das dass die
privaten verbraucher als erstes sind
also die menschen dieses landes und dann
erst die industrie und jetzt ist das
eben nicht nur ein teures gut sondern
offensichtlich auch ein sehr knappes und
die wird steht den finger und sagt ihr
könnt doch irgendwie müsst ihr an dieser
vorrats regelung etwas verändern dass es
wahnsinnig kompliziert auszuhandeln weil
einfach ganze branchen wegbrechen können
wenn wir keine energie mehr haben das
ist ein großes problem und die frage ist
könnten sie sich vorstellen dass die
menschen in diesem land dann
zurücktreten und sagen also lieber habe
ich noch arbeit und habe 17 grad in der
wohnung und einen pullover an als das
ist bei mir warmes und ich arbeitslos
bin
ja das ist nur sehr schwer zu
beantworten zu tage
ich denke dass menschen eben
generell nicht arbeitslos werden wollen
und alle daran interessiert sind dass
wir diese krise so schnell wie möglich
lösen und aktuell habe ich aber das
gefühl dass sie den krieg gegen das
klima beispielsweise ausspielen und sie
spielen auch wiederum unsere
energiesicherheit gegen soziale
gerechtigkeit aus gebräuchen wie
herrscht liebling ihm selbst gesagt hat
'jetzt langfristig wirksame maßnahmen
und das wäre beispielsweise eine
steuerreform die endlich mal die
vermögenden in haftung nimmt und zur
kasse bittet damit wir unsere
energiesicherheit überhaupt finanzieren
können und auch den menschen helfen
könnt ihr jetzt gerade nämlich bankrott
gehen die ich gebe die frage mal weiter
herr berning die gas ist auch knapp wer
bekommt ist zuerst wenn dieser rohstoff
rationiert werden muss die eben
irgendwie versorger und die industrie
die davon ja auch lebens abhängt oder
der bürger das ist eine sehr hässliche
frage ich kann mir schon vorstellen dass
es erst also dass es sinnvoller ist das
natürlich die industrie versorgt ist
damit ich also damit der arbeitnehmer
arbeit hat weil keiner hat etwas
gewonnen wenn man arbeitslos ist aber
dafür hat man zu hause die wohnung war
man muss kein pulver anziehen das ist
ganz klar aber dass er überhaupt in
diese situation gekommen ist für dich
halt schon sehr sehr schwierig und auf
der anderen seite möchte ich auch noch
auf einen anderen punkt zurück kommen
wir hatten in dieser debatte wo es um
die verschuldung und die
staatsverschuldung gegen und womit noch
die jungen generationen viel zu knacken
haben werden diese staatsverschuldung
oder all das was dann auch auf die
jüngeren generationen zukommt das können
wir uns auch nur so leisten oder können
wir auch noch momentan uns noch so
leisten oder zinsen bedienen weil wir
noch im moment sehr sehr starken
mittelstand haben der das ganze halt
auch stemmen kann letztes jahr aber fast
alle millionen menschen das land
verlassen da muss man sich die frage
stellen warum ist das so wunderbar der
ukraine krieg hat noch gar nicht da und
wenn es den leuten noch schlechter geht
und noch schlechter geht und besonders
im mittelstand wird es noch viel viel
mehr leute geben die das land verlassen
und in andere länder gehen wo die
bedingungen besser sind älter besser
sind oder wo ich halt auch versorgt bin
mit energieträgern dass ich sein zuhause
bahn habe
familie die pläne nicht machen sie auch
diese erfahrung dass sie auch ein
arbeitskräfte not haben
wir haben extreme arbeitskräfte not ganz
extrem
wir sind herr scholz bei machen wir auch
ganz froh dass das ukrainische
flüchtlinge
genau in der firma noch haben sind wir
uns untergekommen und arbeiten bei uns
und das ist dann auch eine uns arbeiten
und
geben und daneben ist momentan
allerdings ist es nicht die endlösung
also wir brauchen natürlich auch
arbeitskräfte hier aus dem umfeld mit
wir weiter existieren können damit wir
ausbilden können und damit auch eben
später noch
backwaren brot und brötchen gibt so von
nahversorgung also sie haben das
verfolgt
auch mit welchen ja nicht mehr nur
bitten sondern forderungen die deutsche
wirtschaft an sie herantritt und sagt
wir brauchen eine absicherung unserer
branchen sie müssen sicherstellen dass
die keramikindustrie die chemische
industrie die im medizin industrien
versorgt werden mit einem mit den
technischen gasen die sie brauchen also
fangen die run nicht nur über einen
mangel an energie zu reden sondern uns
irgendwie auf eine rezession
vorzubereiten
stehen uns mit diesen fragen weil sie so
ernst sind wie sie hergestellt werden
aber noch mal damit wir uns da nicht
rein steigern das ist jetzt nicht
zwangsläufig so dass es zu dieser
entwicklung kommt es wäre nur ich
wiederhole das unverantwortlich sich
nicht darauf vorzubereiten
wir haben gesetzliche regelungen die
sehen zum beispiel vor dass
krankenhäuser und pflegeeinrichtungen
dass kitas und schulen
versorgt werden auch dass niemand zu
hause ein solcher kälte ist das man da
nicht leben kann und dann wird das bei
den unternehmen komplizierter weil auch
die zusammenhänge sehr schwer
nachzuvollziehen sind ich gebe ihnen mal
ein beispiel ich habe mit einem
unternehmen gesprochen dass medikamente
herstellt das selber für diesen prozess
nicht so viel gas braucht aber gesagt
hat alle vorprodukte einschließlich der
verpackung sind auf gasproduktion
angewiesen das heißt es geht um viele
ecken und das ist gar nicht schwer vor
gar nicht einfach vorher zu sehen an
welcher stelle nun die richtigen
versorgungsstruktur für songs zu tun
aufrecht erhalten werden müssen oder
nicht darum nochmal bereiten wir uns
genau auf diese situation vor wie können
wir das am besten machen mit am
freiwilligen system das ist ja immer das
intelligenteste wenn man die leute es
dann selber entscheiden dass sie sagen
sie könnten in der situation in anderen
maßen die menschenrechten ja gerne
wissen wie sie sich vorbereiten also
vielleicht noch mal die frage glauben
sie dass man ihnen das abnimmt wenn sie
immer sagen wir bereiten uns davor und
wir haben einen plan
weil die menschen ja jetzt eine wirklich
existenzielle angst haben und die denken
sie sich nicht aus sondern es gibt eine
übereinander gelagerte krise das müssen
wir jetzt noch nicht noch mal alles
aufzählen was ich in diesem land
abspielt sie erleben wie
einer ihrer minister robert habeck
nämlich für seine kommunikation immer
hervorgehoben wird weil der nicht sagt
wir haben einen plan sondern weil er
sagt wir brauchen eure hilfe wir
brauchen eure unterstützung und ihr
müsst jetzt sparen und es kommt auf
euren anteil jetzt an also hier ist die
ganz klare frage warum beziehen sie die
menschen nicht mit konkreten forderungen
ein
wir sind also ich wirklich widersprechen
wenn das erlaubt ist also unbedingt wir
haben ein neues land wir haben längst
die aufträge erteilt um zum beispiel für
die beiden angebote die ich eben gemacht
gesagt habe wie geht man mit einer
mangel lage um vorbereitet zu sein dass
wir das wird entwickelt rechtlich und
das wird auch entwickelt als software
damit wäre falls das passiert
handlungsfähig sind das ist etwas das
ist eine richtig harte arbeit da müssen
ganz viele fachleute herren und diese
aufträge sind alle erteilt dass es nicht
irgendwie gerede sondern das wird
wirklich hart gemacht da wird gesprochen
mit der industrie und mit den verbänden
wie kann man das richtig machen damit
wir möglichst präzise und zielgenau
handeln können also diese versicherung
kann nicht geben und selbstverständlich
macht es sinn wenn wir alle puppen wie
kann man sparen das ist ja ohnehin
sinnvoll aber trotzdem muss man immer
unterscheiden die beiden situationen
es ist wirklich so dass wir einen mangel
lage haben oder es ist so wir bereiten
uns darauf vor dass sie passieren kann
wir sind in der zweiten sind im
augenblick in der zweiten stufe der hat
der alarmmeldung die wir gewissermaßen
der
krisenreaktion die wir haben und das
haben gerne im juli kommen herr scholz
die dritte strophe kann wenn es eine
situation gibt in der wir eine mangel
lage haben das ist aber etwas was nicht
dadurch eintritt dass alle sagen nun sag
doch endlich sie ist da sondern es ist
da wenn sie da ist und das ist etwas was
wir nun gerade auch noch zu vermeiden
suchen indem wir zum beispiel darüber
ist eben gesprochen worden sicher alles
dafür tun dass zum beispiel die turbinen
geliefert werden um die es da geht weil
das wichtig finden aus kanada auch wenn
wir wissen das ist auch ohne die ginge
das ist ja gut sie werden da dann müssen
sie mit den bürgern tut mir leid dann
müssen sie mit den bürgern einfach
klarer kommunizieren ich schätze dass an
robert habeck sehr dass er klar
kommuniziert frei gerade raus und vor
allen dingen so dass die bürger das auch
verstehen wenn sie zum beispiel in einem
interview gefragt werde haben sie denn
noch ideen wo ich zu hause an energie
sparen kann und sie dann sagen habe ich
keine idee dann füllt der bürger sich
veräppelt also da muss man sich
vielleicht vorher ein bisschen besser
vorbereiten und dann mit konkreten ideen
dann auch kommen oder wenn man den
bürgern vorschlägt lasst doch jetzt zu
hause bei der heizung überprüfen dass
die meinen stand setzen das ist ja gar
nicht möglich für so viele heizungen die
wird sich die wir in den häusern haben
oder in den mehrfamilienhäusern oder
auch bei uns sind dagegen das gar nicht
möglich da müssen da schon reale
vorschläge seien die dann auch von den
bürgern umgesetzt werden können ich bin
erst mal dafür dass das reale vorschläge
gibt aber auch nicht dass man so tut als
ob jetzt da der eine knopf ist auf den
man drücken muss und dann ist alles in
ordnung so ist es hier nicht und deshalb
sage ich ganz klar wir müssen uns darauf
vorbereiten und wir sind das land das
die meisten entscheidung bereits
getroffen hat für den fall einer mangel
lage und angefangen hat schon im
dezember des letzten jahres genau diese
fragen zu durchdenken deshalb sind wir
sehr sehr weit mit den
vorbereitungsmaßnahmen aber trotzdem
dürfen wir nicht so tun als wäre die
lage schon da sie kann nur passieren und
das ist eine ernste gefahr und deshalb
reden wir hier zu recht ja auch darüber
und deshalb dass man das auch nicht
wegreden es kann passieren aber es muss
auch nicht also wir hatten klaus müller
auch hier und er hat gesagt ein voller
gasspeicher würde uns für drei monate
helfen jetzt ist der gasspeicher bei
67% ich will nicht zu sehr ins detail
gehen ich will nur sagen wir denken uns
ja nicht aus das ist vielleicht auch
nicht reichen könnte die frage ist frau
michiko wie häufig werden sie
konfrontiert mit der frage ob es
wirklich einen 100-prozentigen cut nach
russland geben soll die deutschen sagen
und die deutsche bundesregierung sagt
annalena baerbock wir sollten uns ein
für allemal von russischen rohstoffen
unabhängig machen denken sie dass das
geschehen wird glauben sie dass wir uns
hundertprozentig von russland unabhängig
machen
ich weiß dass es realistisch ist ich
glaube es gibt schon studien dass
diese
alternativen quellen der energie ich
meine nicht nur
im sinne des der umwelt aber auch bei
anderen partnern er ist das alles geht
und
natürlich wäre ein schneller card ein
härterer schlag und wahrscheinlich
hätten wir dann eine etwas andere
situation bei verhandlungen und bei der
krebsentwicklung aber es ist wie es ist
also wir haben uns eben entschieden zu
sagen wir machen das was geht wir haben
technologie exporte verbunden verboten
das trägt dazu bei dass die russische
wäre erheblich geschädigt wird wir haben
gesagt kohle im herbst zu ende öl am
ende des jahres aber für gas haben wir
das will ich ausdrücklich sagen
entschieden dass wir keine sanktionen
verhängt weil wir in ein paar jahre
brauchen ist das soweit ist und ich will
ausdrücklich sagen dass ich ein bisschen
überrascht bin über all diejenigen die
noch vor ein paar wochen und monaten in
vielen talkshows dieser republik
gesessen haben und gesagt haben man soll
sofort ein ganz enger import städten und
jetzt sich darüber beklagen dass es
konsequenzen geben könnte wenn es so
allmählich weniger wird und plötzlich
demnächst mal passiert also da glaube
ich schon dass wir das gut abgewogen
haben erklärt ende april sie haben dem
spiegel gesagt in einem interview dass
sie sich dagegen entscheiden weil es
millionen arbeitsplätze kosten würden
und weil firmen zu grunde gehen würden
die wir dringend brauchen in diesem land
sie haben es genau mit dieser
wirtschaftlichen konsequenz begründet
und jetzt ist die große frage natürlich
schaffen wir es die ukraine zu retten
oder schaffen wir das klima zu retten
und retten wir parallel dazu noch die
deutsche wirtschaft
die aufgabe oder nichts die aufgabe ist
alles hinzukriegen
was den verlauf des krieges betrifft
muss man ja sagen hängt das ja auch
davon ab ob es uns gelingt putin von
seiner brutalen aggressionen abzubringen
deshalb machen wir all die dinge wird
diese schon gesprochen haben und die
allen bekannt sind und das haben wir
aber nicht in der hand ist soll dazu
führen dass er sagt ich war auf ich
beende diesen krieg ich ziehe meine
truppen zurück was die frage betrifft
können wir das gleichzeitig hinkriegen
müssen wir sogar ich habe im bundestag
gesagt jetzt erst recht und das ist nun
gerade der richtige tag wo wir uns hier
zusammenfinden wir haben heute im
deutschen bundestag gesetze beschlossen
die dazu führen sollen dass deutschland
mit riesigem tempo den ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien vorantreibt damit
wir unabhängig werden von import von
fossilen ressourcen auch von denen die
wir aus russland importieren
lambrecht sie haben uns im
koalitionsvertrag versprochen dass sie
uns auf 1 105 grad fahrt bringen und
raus aus dem fossilen zeitalter jetzt
machen sie mit uns gerade eine zeitreise
zurück ins fossile zeitalter und ihre
klimaschädlichen investitionen in gas im
senegal helfen uns auch in der aktuellen
gasknappheit eben nicht und das ist
meiner meinung nach eine täuschung der
öffentlichkeit wenn sie sagen das würde
ins uns in dieser aktuellen krise helfen
dass man diese gasfelder nämlich gebaut
hat dauert es mindestens fünf jahre es
gibt noch mal erklärt auch heute
natürlich die genehmigung in einer
notsituation auf kohlekraftwerke
zurückzugreifen das hat die regierung
und der deutsche bundestag heute gerade
beschlossen wie groß ist ihre sorge frau
lamprecht dass da eine infrastruktur
entsteht und zu sagen etwas reanimiert
wird was wir eigentlich verabschieden
wollen er meine angst ist natürlich sehr
groß weil es geht hier um dem oder tot
und wir versuchen gerade putins massiven
brutalen angriffs krieg zu beenden
aber wenn wir jetzt die kriege von
morgen auslösen und ihre kinder
vielleicht irgendwann meine kinder in
klimakriege sterben werden haben wir
damit leider auch nichts gewonnen und
deswegen habe ich davor angst aber was
mich eben
enttäuscht ist dass sie offensichtlich
nicht die studien lesen die zeigen dass
es möglich ist schneller aus den
fossilen energien heraus zu kommen was
mich enttäuscht ist dass sie auch auf eu
ebene umgesetzt haben das jetzt gas und
atom ein öko label bekommen da waren sie
maßgeblich mit beteiligt und das macht
für mich dann auch einfach keinen sinn
mehr und wie groß ist ihre sorge in eine
solche welt noch kinder zu setzen pro
lamprecht also jetzt gerade sehe ich
nicht dass es moralisch vertretbar ist
noch kinder in diese welt zu sehen sie
diese gesellschaft vor der frage eben
entweder die ukraine zu retten oder das
klima oder gar nicht weil man kann diese
beiden krisen zu tal zusammen denken
also
erzählt habe es gibt es genügend studien
die zeigen dass wir jetzt auf diese
massive
klima verschlechterungen mit einem
massiven klima rettungsprogramm
reagieren müssen das bedeutet nicht nur
in erneuerbare energien sondern
beispielsweise auch eine verkehrswende
die wird gerade von der fdp 30 blockiert
und da frage ich mich warum haben sie
denn da nicht mehr auf den tisch und
sagen
warum haben sie denn da nicht auf den
tisch herr scholz dann spricht eine
engagierte 21 jährige die sich im
jugendrat der generation stiftung
engagiert und ich will und los ihr
engagement mein engagement in dieser
frage sehr sehr groß und das was wir uns
vorgenommen haben ist ja doch eine
nummer findet hier nicht mitzahlen
langweilen aber muss man mal sagen
deutschland produziert heute 600
terawattstunden strom wir wollen zum
ende des jahrzehnts 800 terawattstunden
haben und am ende des nächstens die
doppelte menge weil wir wollen dass
industrielle prozesse die heute mit gas
mit kohle mit öl passieren zukünftig mit
strom und wasserstoff aus erneuerbaren
quellen passieren so und dann zu sehen
sich während der tb abkochen und das
lassen wir uns nicht wir haben aber eine
gute vereinbarung getroffen und die
beinhaltet zum beispiel genau diesen
massiven ausbau und den umstieg auf
andere erzeugungsformen von energie die
vollständig co2 neutral ist und
deutschland will eines der ersten und
vielleicht das erste industrieland seien
eher die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der
welt die co2 neutral wirtschaft sind
schon 2045 oder schaffen wir auch es
geht ja nicht nur um den strom es geht
ja um wärme es geht um verkehrs geht um
landwirtschaft und gerade im wärme und
verkehrssektor passiert da eben noch
viel zu wenig und jetzt gerade so viele
millionen in einen neuen monats einen
neuen euro ticket für drei monate zu
investieren anstatt zu sagen wir müssen
langfristig
erschwingliche bahntickets ermöglichen
damit klimaschutz auch mal sozial
gerecht über damit leute wirklich von
ihrem auto auf die bahn umsteigen warum
passiert so was nicht und können sie mir
garantieren dass dieses jahr noch so
eine verkehrswende in gang gesetzt wird
sie haben schon gestanden herbergen sie
sind überhaupt kein grüner wir holen
ganz kurz auch noch mal
ihre meinung dazu
würden sie das genauso befürworten und
sagen da muss viel viel mehr passieren
das muss total viel passieren es ist ja
nicht nur das thema ukraine oder wie man
in der vergangenheit mit russland
umgegangen ist dass man sich abhängig
gemacht hat von der energie die aus
russland kommt und schlecht vorbereitet
war und auch immer noch keine
alternativen energien vorangetrieben hat
sondern es sind ja noch viele andere
dinge das ist die rente ich mache mir
sorgen ob ich überhaupt eine rente
bekomme er wenn das rentenniveau sich
weiter so entwickelt wie es das tut ich
mache mir sorgen über die
krankenhauslandschaft ich mache mir
sorgen darüber wie wir überhaupt in
diesem land noch medizin machen wollen
oder nicht wenn man über cook nach nrw
dass die kollegen da seit fast zehn
wochen am streiken sind und da passiert
nicht wirklich viel auch nicht dass ich
bekannt wird von der politik dann sehe
ich dort auch schwarz soziale
gerechtigkeit fehlt mir auch sehr in
diesem land und ich muss auch wirklich
ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe das gefühl
ich verfolge gerne politik auch täglich
ich habe das gefühl dass die fdp die
größte bremse in dieser koalition ist
aber dass sie leider gezwungen sind mit
der fdp zusammen zu arbeiten weil sie
sonst einfach keine regierung bilden
können aber das ist das gefühl was ich
habe dass die fdp eine sehr große bremse
ist in dieser regierung ich glaube und
sie sind kein grüner das haben sie
vorher schon mal verraten und
darf ich dazwischen werfen noch mal die
klare frage
sozialer gerechtigkeit wäre das nächste
die situation eben in der gesundheit
können wir jetzt nicht auch auf diesem
spiel beim noch mit besprechen aber
haben sie den klaren kompass das
zumutungen fair verteilt werden müssen
unbedingt deshalb haben wir die eingangs
besprochen und 30 milliarden als es
losging auf den weg gebracht und gesagt
das ist nicht das ende wir werden
weiteres tun und dazu vertreten wir uns
aber mit anderen um das konkret zu
machen und wir haben in dieser koalition
mit den drei koalitionsparteien eine
haben sie ihn genannt beschlossen dass
es ab oktober einen höheren mindestlohn
von zwölf euro gibt wir haben
beschlossen dass es der vollkommen
aufgefressen wird von der inflation die
wir jetzt ist es trotzdem eine
steigerung je nachdem wo der lohn der
beteiligten nicht die ziemlich erheblich
ist und sich auch auswirken wird und das
ist ja eigentlich ein zeichen und wir
werden da weitermachen ich habe mir das
fest vorgenommen
das gilt auch für besser löhne im
pflegebereich und bessere
arbeitsbedingungen pflegebereich das
gehört zu den vereinbarungen die die
regierung getroffen hat als sie sich
zusammengesetzt hat und wir losgelegt
haben und das werden wir auch tun und
ich finde noch mal da sind jetzt so
viele themen zusammen was die frage wie
die frage der staatsschulden habe ich
schon gesagt er ist kriegen wir hin weil
wir ein wirtschaftsstarkes land sind mit
modernen technologien die frage der
krise untergehen wenn sie so weiter und
die wird nicht untergehen ich
widerspreche ihnen und ich sage
ausdrückt wir werden auch es hinbekommen
ein stabiles rentensystem zu haben zu
den vereinbarungen die wir zutritt
getroffen haben zählt dass wir das
rentenniveau stabilisieren und das ist
nicht mehr sinken wird nicht nur
geschützt bis 225 wie bisher ja auch
lange darüber hinaus das ist eine feste
vereinbarung das machen wir auch und wir
werden dafür sorgen dass kinder besser
dastehen mit der kindergrundsicherung
wir werden bei denen graf angewiesen
sind ein bürgergeld machen schaffen dass
sie besser abgestützt wenn sie auf
öffentliche unterstützung angewiesen
sind aber ich will ausdrücklich sagen
ich teile ihre auffassung zur klimakrise
nicht deutschland wird das land mit dem
größten tempo sein und das ist auch
richtig wissenschaftlich falsch weil
ganz schlüssig was ich tun soll co2
budget aufgebraucht das sagen ihre
eigenen berater und sachverständigenrat
für umweltfragen habe ich möchte ihnen
widersprechen wenn ich das darf
was ich nicht möchte ist dass wir sagen
jetzt hören wir einfach auf und stellen
ein paar fabriken ein damit wir weniger
co2 emittieren ich möchte das jetzt
trifft krupp zum beispiel entscheidet
ein neues stahlwerk zu bauen das
allerdings nicht mit kohle arbeitet und
auch nicht mit gas sondern das arbeitet
mit strom und wasserstoff wenn das jetzt
gemacht wird dort das ein paar jahre bis
das gebaut wird und dann ist es aber so
dass deutschland zeigt dass es möglich
ist industrieland zu sein und co2
neutral zu wirtschaften und das nützt
der ganzen welt und das will ich auch
mal sagen ich habe mich sehr
ausdrücklich und viel unterhalt mit zum
beispiel den regierungschefs von indien
indonesien den afrikanischen
regierungschefs und anderen und die
sagen ganz klar okay ihr habt jetzt 200
jahre industrieland
wir wollen auch gut leben und wir werden
wegen euch jetzt nicht auf den wohlstand
verzichten also wenn die antworten die
antwort die ich ihm geben mussten die
wir als deutsche hingeben können ist ich
hab was besseres denn die technologien
die wir hier entwickeln was jetzt co2
neutrale mobilität betrifft mit
elektrofahrzeugen zum beispiel mit den
ausbau des öffentlichen verkehrs wo wir
sehr viel geld investiert werden
das sind wege die wir beschreiten die
funktionieren auch für euch weil ein
dass es geht aber erstmal greenwashing
ist noch ein stichwort mit irgendwie
atom und erdgas sind von dem eu
parlament und der eu sanktionierte
alternative energien und bekommen das
label das ist eine entscheidung die sie
nachträglich auch oder die sie mit
möglich gemacht haben herrscht
das ist eine nicht ganz korrekte
beschreibung und einen traurigen den
tatbestand wir haben nicht zugestimmt
hat sich diesen bericht noch sagen darf
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass es an die
regeln gibt die für uns selber
funktioniert aber in deutschland sind
wir uns völlig einig dass atomenergie
nicht grün ist und auch ganz
warum haben sie sich da nicht gegen
eingesetzt wir haben als deutsche
regierung dagegen gestimmt und haben
versucht etwas aufzuhalten was wir fast
nicht mehr hätten halten können sei
die nachrichtenlage ist falsch deshalb
noch mal die kleine also der hinweis es
gibt ein gesetz das hat das eu parlament
gemacht mit dem europäischen rat
zusammen dem steht drin dass es so eine
taxonomie von staatswegen gibt in der
gesagt wird wie bewertet man
finanzanlagen für alle diejenigen die
mit dem wort taxonomien nicht so viel
anfangen können und wir haben gesagt das
ist eigentlich kein so guter einfall ich
fand das immer falsch weil irgendwann
kommt die politik wenn es der staat
macht der solche kriterien festlegt und
bestimmt das ein
kämpfen oder dagegen kämpfen möchten ist
mögen die differenz bei deutschland
fragt ist noch mal es war am
jahreswechsel so weit dass die eu
kommission ohne dass wir es auf halten
hätten können irgendwas hätte festsetzen
können und dann haben wir dafür gesorgt
dass es noch halbwegs so zu uns passt
aber es ist nicht etwas was wir noch
hätten verhindern können das hätte fünf
jahre vorher passieren müssen als einige
leute gedacht hatten wenn der staat
solche kriterien festlegt ist das ein
guter einfall die sind jetzt alle eines
besseren belehrt aber das hilft mir
nicht das glaube ich ihnen nicht aber da
können wir auch noch ewig krieg war
diskutieren ich verstehe aber nicht
warum sie beispielsweise auch ganz offen
auf deutschland ebene in gasfelder im
senegal investieren das alles geht auf
kosten meiner generation und ich habe
gerade das gefühl junge menschen werden
von ihnen zu den verlierern dieser
krisenzeiten gemacht und so sehe ich
keine zukunft in ihrer zukunfts
koalition wie habe ich sehe das anders
und will gerne was sagen wir haben jetzt
gesagt wir steigen aus aus dem wollen
verhindern dass wir so viel gas
importieren müssen nach europa aus
russland das sind mal die summe zu sagen
158 milliarden kubikmeter jedes jahr
nach ganz westeuropa wenn jetzt alle
dass reduzieren uns vielleicht sogar
theoretisch auf null ginge bedeutet das
dass die woanders her kommen müssen und
das zweite was sehr wichtig ist es ist
schon sehr schwierig ländern die jetzt
ihre energie mit kohle bekommen zu sagen
sie dürfen nicht wie wir zwischendurch
das mit gas machen und das ist finde ich
ein eigenwilliger standpunkt zu sagen
wir erzählen den ländern in afrika wie
sie jetzt ihren weg zu einer
klimaneutralität organisieren sollen
sondern da muss man schon ein bisschen
zusammenarbeiten und auch auf augenhöhe
mit den reden und nicht in den ländern
die jetzt 200 jahre industriegeschichte
hinter sich haben sagen wir haben aber
größere ideen furcht sowie eine gegen
bemerkt noch es geht nicht nur darum
dort zu investieren den ländern des
südens zu helfen
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung zu haben das
support ich total und ich denke das muss
aber eben auch auf einem ökologischen
weg passieren es geht ja vielmehr darum
dass wir dieses gas auch importieren und
sie haben uns ein ende aller
klimaschädlichen investitionen auch
dieses jahr versprochen und jetzt
starten sie wieder damit also bin ich
habe ihnen versprochen und die kann
regierung dass wir 2045 co2 neutral
wirtschaften werden und in diesem
versprechen war immer der satz
eingebunden übergangsweise werden wir
wenn wir aus der kohle aussteigen und
aus der atomenergie gas benötigen und
das ist auch unverändert und nun
brauchen wir sogar die kohle wieder
zurück und müssen die richter dass das
ein provisorium ist oder keins und eben
vielleicht doch dann eine struktur
entsteht die an die man sich gewöhnt
wenigstens ist nein ich sie sich nicht
gewöhnen wir sind herr berning das
wollte ich unbedingt bei ihnen auch noch
mal nachfragen bei der letzten frage wie
sehr sie das gefühl haben dass es fair
auf allen schultern verteilt wird was da
jetzt zu reden ist die gewerkschaften
machen darauf aufmerksam wie groß in
diesem land eigentlich die gewinne waren
im letzten jahr und wie gleichzeitig die
armut gewachsen ist das ist keine
unwichtige frage die man mir jetzt zu
allerlei dennoch mitnehmen kann sehen
sie dieses unterhaken auch deshalb
problematisch weil
einige davon offensichtlich ausgenommen
sind total also ich finde schon dass so
eine große soziale
also soziale ungerechtigkeit haben in
deutschland wir sind glaube ich ganz
ganz oben beim niedriglohnsektor in
deutschland seit seit der seit der
hartz-iv-reform das ist auch ein
riesiges problem der mindestlohn von
zwölf euro mit zwölf euro das ist das
ist ein witz also wenn man das wenn man
das hochrechnet und ich ziehe dann die
steuern ab mit lohnsteuerklasse 1 dann
mehr kann man sich das arbeiten auch
schon fast wieder sparen weil man dann
unterm strich besser wegkommt
aber ich find's einfach ich will es
einfach ungerecht verteilt und man
sollte wirklich an die unternehmen
rangehen die millionen oder milliarden
gewinne erwirtschaftet haben jetzt nicht
nur während der ukraine krise sondern
auch davor in den zwei jahren von corona
da hätte man an dieser ganzen
unternehmen rangehen müssen und man muss
auch einfach mal
politik der klaren kante machen es macht
für mich keinen sinn dass zb unternehmen
wie bmw sagt ja uns geht es ganz
schlecht wir müssen unsere unsere
mitarbeiter irgendwie in kurzarbeit
schicken und schüttet dann aber später
dividenden an die aktionäre aus das
funktioniert einfach nicht das beißt
sich total
und wir müssen einfach zu dieser
sozialen gerechtigkeit in sonst sonst
werden viele menschen diesem land den
rücken kehren und dann woanders hingehen
auch mercedes herrschte pling ihnen geht
es genauso
wir haben gesehen dass gerade in der
korona krise einige firmen sehr sehr
viel geld verdient haben und
keine steuern bezahlt oder kaum steuern
bezahlt haben und die die kleinen in den
innenstädten die letten sind viele
kleine firmen kaputt gegangen und ich
bin der meinung dass man auch groß auch
wenn sie multinational sind und ihren
firmensitz woanders haben ich kann die
auch in deutschland besteuern ich weiß
genau wie viel umsatz in deutschland
gemacht wird und ich weiß was sie zu der
gewinnmarge machen es muss doch möglich
sein von amazon da in den den gewinn zu
besteuern es bei jeder kleinen firma in
deutschland muss es gemacht werden damit
wird's gemacht und wenn die steuer nicht
ordentlich bezahlt geht er ins gefängnis
müssen wahrscheinlich auch schon
ausgerechnet macht bei ihnen nämlich die
firmenkasse herr scholz als ist ein
altes lied aber es würde die dinge ja
auch ein bisschen vereinfachen wenn man
das gefühl hätte dass dieses unterhaken
können teilt es war sich alle irgendwie
auch weil die zumutungen einigermaßen
fair verteilt sind wann wird es gelingen
eben über gewinne oder gar keine
gezahlten steuern der deutschen
gesellschaft der europäischen
gesellschaft der welt sie reden jetzt
nur für deutschland also verzeichnet
wie zurückzuholen oder zu sagen da
werden gewinne und umsätze gemacht und
hier einsteigen kurze antwort wenn es
geht ja kurze antwort erstens dass mit
der globalen mindestbesteuerung die ich
ja schon als finanzminister
vorangetrieben hat ist jetzt fast durch
es fehlt noch ein land in europa das
zustimmen muss und wir gehen davon aus
dass wir es hinkriegen weil die usa das
mit uns gemeinsam durchsetzen wollen und
dann wird das jetzt endlich kommt also
diese sache die so viele bürgerinnen
bürger und mich auch seit jahren
umtreibt obwohl gelöst und über gering
und was die frage der eines gerechteren
steuersystems betrifft muss man nicht
nicht
überzeugen dass stand in meinem
wahlprogramm aber wir haben keine
gesetzgebungs mehrheit für
steuererhöhungen das muss man da es
weder die erde diejenigen die ich finde
muss ja auch fair sein das ist etwas wo
unterschiedliche überzeugung existieren
und dafür hat es ja auch in den letzten
jahren keine gegeben das ist also jetzt
kein neuer umstand ich persönlich
allerdings steht zu dem was im
wahlprogramm steht
doch als aller erstes mal gerechtigkeit
sozialdemokratie entspricht es denn
ihren vorstellungen von gerechtigkeit
wenn seit den zeiten in denen sie
finanzminister waren die zahl der
millionäre in die höhe schießen und
gleichzeitig wie jetzt gerade 14
milliarden entschuldigen und 14
millionen arbeite als betroffene haben
erstens gegen mehr millionäre habe ich
nichts einzuwenden wenn das das ergebnis
wirtschaftlichen wachstums wissen von
großem erfolg davon profitieren wir alle
ich finde sie sollten fair besteuert
werden das ist mein sozialdemokratischer
beitrag ich bin also für viele
millionäre die gerne steuern zahlen um
das so zu übersetzen aber natürlich habe
ich
große sorgen weil das stimmt dass sie
gesagt haben und war sondern dass so
viele bürgerinnen und bürger nicht gut
zurecht kommen mit dem was sie verdienen
der mindestlohn ist ja nicht die
maßnahme aber eine ganz wichtige um die
wir in deutschland lange reise haben und
dass sie kommt wäre es ausdrücklich
sagen dass wir dafür dass wir alles
dafür tun müssen dass gerade in den
unteren und mittleren bereich der
einkommenssteigerung zustande kommen und
das kann auch gelingen indem wir dafür
sorgen dass in den bereichen drüber
einfluss haben zum beispiel bei ihnen
der pflege bessere löhne vereinbart
werden dass es jetzt tatsächlich nicht
mehr richtig auszudiskutieren weil wir
am ende der sendung sind die frage war
ja kann man den spitzenverdienern den
millionären und milliardären dieses
landes da gegebenenfalls mehr zumuten
als wir das bisher tun ich muss jetzt
mit disziplin und gucken auf die uhr ein
dankeschön in die runde schicken ein
großes dankeschön in die runde schicken
und zu markus lanz verweisen der heute
unter anderem sigmar gabriel zu gast hat
und wir sind uns hier am tisch
wenigstens einig dass wir tatsächlich in
dramatischen seiten leben und ist an
ganz ganz vielen ecken noch ganz viel zu
tun bleibt vielen dank und sie kommen
gut durch diese nacht und wir sehen und
wenn sie mit
[Musik]